hey what's up guys my name is ashana
welcome back to the game engine series
so
first and foremost if you haven't
watched the video detailing what we are
doing with the rest of this series
please watch it i'll have it linked up
there it's called let's talk it's it is
pretty long at least watch the first
like 11 minutes or so up until we get up
to the planning thing uh because it's
just gonna give a little bit of insight
as to where we're going if you are
interested in the goals of this series
and you're not just watching these
videos one of them that is
definitely my wholehearted
recommendation to you but also the rest
of that video even though it is long is
planning literally everything that we're
going to be doing like literally just
everything the rest of the series has
basically been planned already and
effective immediately like as of today
we are following that plan um and so
what's going to happen is i will be live
streaming every single thursday at least
in australian time starting from around
11 a.m australian eastern standard time
i will be live streaming uh myself
actually working on this stuff i might
open up some stuff and show you guys in
a minute um but uh i will be live
streaming myself uh kind of developing
hazel 2d which is this new project
we've kind of renamed it from the game
engine series version of hazel to hazel
2d
i did a stream earlier today in which i
did that and that's going to be
happening every thursday if you are
interested in more details then uh just
watch the stream uh the twitch files
will stay up for about 60 days
and you can also check the schedule
which actually let's just let's just
bounce into it let's just bounce into it
so we have a schedule i'll have these
these links below if you go to my twitch
page and then you click on schedule
you'll see when the next stream is and
you can see that i've working on hazel
2d like i've got that locked in every
thursday around this time so if you want
to see when that is in your time zone
check it out there otherwise the streams
will remain up here you can see this one
was like four hours ago um this is
basically what i just did today right so
what's gonna that that's gonna be the
new structure we're gonna be planning
this stuff during live streams working
on stuff actively during live streams
and then everything from these live
streams goes into a branch called dev so
this new branch in the official kind of
hazel public git hub repository
which i'll also that's also linked in
every episode so it'll be in the
description below
we have this dev branch right and this
dev branch is what i did today and
that's what we're going to be talking
about so uh
because a lot of people want to actually
still see this series as a live coding
live programming series um
i will still write all the code out and
it might even be slightly different to
the way that i did it in the live stream
but i use these live streams to just
test stuff out and that way i can
produce these condensed episodes which
is what you're going to be seeing today
but i will still discuss everything i
just know the code that has been written
and actually you could even say that i
know it two-fold because step one is
writing it
usually for hazel like for real hazel
the the patreon version of hazel that's
3d and everything that's like the big
kind of proper engine that i'm working
on so that obviously already has
you know a lot of the stuff that was
detailed out in the road map
so that's kind of like step one i've
done it there but then i do it on live
stream in hazel 2d's context and then i
i jam it in right so i don't mind doing
that because
it lets me
think about how i'm going to teach it
and it's just preparation for teaching
it but also there'll be a lot of cases
in which i will simplify the design or
change the design because what i did the
first time i mean you you guys probably
know if you've you know been programming
for a while or you're software engineers
you know that like when you do when you
solve a problem the first time
if you were to solve it again you'd
probably do it slightly differently and
so i kind of like that i think it's a
good idea to to do that and to do it on
stream so that if you really want every
drop of content you can get that and
then finally after the 60 days when
twitch uh will delete that vod the vod
will go up onto
um like an unlisted youtube channel for
patreons uh so that way you can access
the entire backlog of any uh pretty much
every live stream i've ever done which i
think is pretty cool so that is kind of
like a little bit of like uh planning
like where we're at and what we're gonna
do now the second thing i wanted to
quickly show before we get into this i
know there's a lot of like meta stuff
going on here but we have this um
we have this road map and this is what i
also spent doing
like in the live stream and i talked
about these things in more detail there
again it's kind of similar to the
planning video that i did it's called
let's talk but
this actually has a progression so that
planning video everything was out of
order it was just here's a bunch of
stuff that we need i don't know what the
order of progression is this if you read
the read meme you can see it contains a
feature roadmap and read this board from
left to right that's the order of
progression right so a few things will
kind of overlap here and there but you
can see that we basically
we're going to be basically starting off
with physics which is actually not what
we're doing today but we're basically
going to be starting off with physics
and then moving on to scripting and then
doing an asset anyway you guys can read
all this there's a bunch of stuff here
it's going to keep getting filled out as
time goes on but that is basically where
we are at now the first thing that i
want to do and i'm going to start doing
this during live streams but i want to
kind of look at the issues and the pull
requests that we have now this stuff i
will i'll look at all of these in the
next live stream right
i'm not going to waste time doing that
stuff now but what i do want is
this uh
i believe it's this one i want to make
sure that i get the first one
because when do i release that
um i think it is this one
uh because this is i believe the fix for
the rendering bug that we had in the
previous episode right so the previous
episode which i'll have linked up there
by the way not the kind of talking one
but the actual yeah i need to fix that
i'm going layout um
the actual kind of previous episode
uh i was just playing with you i'm gooey
layout at some point don't even know why
it's like this
um so the previous episode
in which we actually did real
development we had an issue i think
where if we applied a texture to this so
we now have the ability through the
content browser to actually drag in
textures like the cherno logo it just
looks weird i mean it looks like it like
for certain pixels it decides to use no
texture which is why you see pink for
other pixels as it rasterizes this it
chooses to display the texture and you
get this weird thing
and someone has fixed it so this is the
pull request so what i want to do is i
mean i can see the changes here this is
a really quick one so i'll just accept
the pull request but you can see that um
if we kind of go through this fix and
maybe do a bit of a code review moving
text index out of the struct because it
you can't have flat variables
unfortunately in a struct they all kind
of get interpolated so what the flat
keyword does in jealous cell is it
basically means that when you go from
the vertex shader to the fragment shader
we don't want any interpolation right
usually
um i don't know how much let me know
what you think about this depth um i
guess this is the game engine series and
it's an educational series not a let's
watch turn and write code for now
without saying anything serious so
because of that i will explain like a
little bit of this stuff but basically
we have a vertex shader um let's make
that fast please we have a vertex shader
we have a fragment shader right so the
way that this effectively works is that
we have is this lagging what on earth
man
why is it lagging
unbelievable i have like 30 i've got 16
cores 32 threads in this machine and it
can't handle a couple things at once
whatever so
maybe paints just anyway whatever let's
just move on so we have a triangle right
and we have certain uh data at the
vertex positions of these of this
triangle right so in this case you can
see that we have for example a text
index so if we have that text index here
we have like i'll just label it i so we
have a text index of like you know you
know
maybe text index is isn't the best
[Music]
example here but let's just say we have
a color
and the color
has a value of 1 here a value of 2 here
and a value of 3 here well the thing is
the vertex shader runs on vertices so we
have three vertices here one two three
vertices so it's pretty clear what the
values are but when you get into a
fragment shader you have the same
triangle but obviously the fragment
shader runs for every pixel is visible
so if it's running for every pixel is
visible then
like
what happens if we try and move move
this data not move it but access the
data from the vertex here in the
fragment shader like we do when we use a
varying as they used to be called or
here like an output variable right so
what happens is it interpolates the
values so in other words if i pick a
pixel that is halfway between these two
vertices i'm going to because it's
linear interpolation get the value 1.5
because it's halfway between one and two
right if i'm here i'm going to basically
linearly interpolate between three
values and get that result right that's
a really good example as to why smooth
normals work we might have a sphere that
is technically like some kind of
octahedron maybe not that low like kind
of fidelity and low amount of triangles
but you get the point that our sphere is
never going to be perfectly round i
guess it's still made up of triangles
however it looks very smooth when we
light it if we look at it lit the kind
of falloff of the color is so smooth you
can't tell that it's flat shaded and
that's because these
normals are smooth right as long as you
export your mesh with smooth
shading right they will be smooth and
per pixel they will be interpolated and
that's how you get smooth shading so
the idea is we have this concept of
interpolation and since we have this
concept of interpolation
um we want to be able to turn it off
sometimes and a good example is if we
know that we have a flat float text
index to be 100 honest i don't know why
it's a float because we cast it to an
int anyway and we use an interior anyway
so it's not like we're avoiding integers
um that might need a bit of a revisit
but the point is flat we don't want
interpolation on it
and it's been removed from the struct
because you can't mark this float as
flat if it's inside a struct this can't
be done i don't know why that's just the
way it is um it might be to do with how
it actually sends that data over or
something
but there we go so in flat float again
and then we switch from using input or
text index from within the structure
using just v text index so this is a
great pull request all the um
all the code is in the correct style you
know you've got the v underscore the
naming is correct
um so i'm going to squash and merge this
[Music]
i'm going to rename it though to fixed
fixed text index
being
interpolated in shaders
in in um what's the shader called
in texture shader
okay so that's it boom not gonna spend
too much time on this uh so how do we
then do that so well i mean what does
that effectively do um with the pull
request it just means that that pull
request um i think this is in the
content browser branch right um yeah so
that pull request has now been properly
accepted you can see that the latest
commit is in fact by a standtall007
so that means that if i were to find um
i've got so much stuff going on in fork
you don't even want to see it
including some some secret stuff that i
can't show
but um
what i'm going to do now is just
basically pull i'm going to pull my own
code even though i it used to be up to
date but now obviously we have a pull
request merged in so that is the plan
okay so i have indeed pulled the code
you can see that uh change over here now
one thing that is worth mentioning um
definitely because people forget this
all the time is that currently because
we don't have any kind of like uh you
know we don't have like a hash system
for our shader we don't know if the
shader has changed so we have to
manually delete the shader from the
cache so usually i just clear the cache
by just deleting the folder you can just
delete this entire cache folder if you
want and then it will regenerate the
shader binary which is important
otherwise we'll still be using the old
shader so don't forget to do that
um
[Music]
in hazel in real hazel we
just basically
hash the string um the entire shader
string source code using a hash function
into like a 32-bit i think it is hash
and then we store that in like a
database that's not really a database
like a yaml file um and then that way we
can basically read the shader source
code compare it to the string i'm sorry
read the shadow source code hash it
compare it to the hash that's being
stored in the database and then if they
don't match we know the shader source
code has changed and we need to
recompile the shader so that's how we
deal with it it's pretty common
um because that way again we don't we
don't need to uh manually delete
anything if you just modify shader code
it will recompile just that shader next
time you launch um
hazel
obviously you can also reload shaders by
manually clicking reload next to them in
the editor um but yeah okay so if we uh
try that again um i haven't tested this
by the way but i'm assuming that is in
fact the solution and that person doing
the pull request has fixed it so if we
look at
textures channel logo okay there you go
you can see it's completely fixed now
the channel logo might look weird in
terms of colors that's because we
multiply these two values together
remember so texture and color gets
multiplied together so if we just set
the color to be white
then you can see that now we have no
problem and we even have uh transparency
working properly that's a complete fluke
if we make them all churner logos i
think we'll start to see problems
because
all right wrong one
um so you can see like in this case i
can't see that
texture is being cut off so um the
reason this is happening is because
first of all uh we don't have any kind
of on order independent transparency
instead we're rendering these in a
particular order and i'm not even sure
what the order is this one looks like
this one is being rendered first because
it's being rounded first there's no
there's no data in the frame buffer for
it to blend with anything and so we get
just the clear color um even though it's
stuck behind us because this is being
rendered first and that starts being
rendered later so what we would want to
do is either use like a order
independent uh transparency kind of
algorithm
and set up or we would want to sort from
back to front when it comes to
transparent
materials right but again this is more
of a 3d thing um
don't know if you necessarily need this
for 2d
because you could just render
well what could you do i mean you could
just have a back to front rendering
setup for 2d anyway and disable depth
testing but anyway we're going to get
into this stuff this is i'm getting a
little bit distracted but i hope that
this kind of general conversation
um is uh kind of beneficial to you guys
who are still watching this series uh
because you want like just a little bit
more of a game engine kind of
environment rather than a step-by-step
tutorial series that's what i'm really
hoping for but anyway let's get on with
our task for today officially which is
um and again i'm going to be referring
to the code that i wrote earlier in the
live stream so if you want to see if you
really want to truly live format channel
figuring out this code for the first
time ever then check out the live stream
although it jokes on you because in that
live stream i was kind of stealing code
from from from big hazel so yeah lol
anyway so what are we doing today let's
get to it so
today we are going to be creating a play
button why because first of all we
already have the ability to kind of run
our scene as a runtime kind of it's like
half done right if you actually look at
the scene um
let's take a look at this scene.h right
then you can see that inside c dot h we
have on update runtime and on updated
editor we have these two functions right
they do slightly different things the
biggest difference between them apart
from like other script stuff the biggest
rendering difference between them is
that here we actually use the camera
from the camera component on an entity
in our scene whereas here we pass in an
editor camera right the reason why this
is important is because the first thing
that we want to do is physics right we
want to integrate box 2d um and then we
want to start adding physics components
and then of course we need to simulate
our physics and how we're going to do
that at the moment we don't have a play
button to hit play or we don't have a
simulate button to hit simulate
i also showed how like
proper hazel
works in that regard and i even set up a
2d scene for proper hazel so definitely
check out that live stream if you want
to see that
but other than that um it doesn't really
matter too much i'm not going to show it
here but the point is that to do this
like i just decided to be slightly
better if we were to just
um you know kind of even though we have
a play button here and also i think in
run time we have play button and editor
as well we've got it in a few places
it's probably better to do it now
because that way we can we have
something to actually simulate and we
can easily do that using the ui and also
it's not going to take long so that's
what we're going to do this week and
then next week we're going to jump back
into um you know integrating box 2d
adding physics components to our entity
to our entity component system and all
that good stuff so
let's dive into this so the first thing
we need is some resources now i actually
have two icons which i prepared earlier
and these are directly from from hazel
um
so
uh let's see
hazelnut resources and then what i want
to do is um
into icons uh
content browser i guess this is all for
the editor anyway but so i'll just do
play button stop button right these are
two icons there's really nothing special
about them they are literally just this
and then the other stop one you can
imagine is um even better
uh it's just this right it's a very
simple icon if anything i think they're
slightly low resolution i'd almost like
to increase the resolution on them 32x32
is quite small because they will be so i
might change them later because you
might want to make the toolbar bigger
but the first thing we need to do is
actually create a toolbar so my vision
for this is kind of what it is in hazel
um in in proper hazel which is like
there's a toolbar basically up here that
has like a play button so what we're
going to do is make a play button that
turns into a stop button when we
actually you know are playing a scene
and then if i click it i want to be able
to play a scene
so let's do that so let's let's head on
over into editor layer and we're going
to start designing this so this is going
to be an im gui uh panel basically like
an i'm going window everything's an i'm
going window so
let's go ahead and um
[Music]
make a function because i want to make i
want to organize this nicely we'll have
some like ui
panels
and i want to call it ui underscore
uh toolbar
right so um basically anything that
starts with ui is specifically a ui
panel the reason why i want to do this
is because currently and let's move this
close to like onion gui render we'll put
it probably right under i'm going render
this is getting very cluttered right i
mean if you look at this
there's a stats window like it's just
nice to have these in separate functions
so that if you're looking for like oh i
don't know i want the toolbar you can
just easily jump to it it's a separate
function everything's nice and clean and
we'll call this before we end the dock
space like that it doesn't matter too
much you can still dock it even even if
it's not inside the dock space but i'll
do it this way
so ui toolbar and then i'm going to
basically start copying some code that i
wrote during the live stream so we're
going to begin
we're going to begin this
window we're going to call it um
it doesn't really matter like i don't
think we have to use this double hash so
if you guys don't know if you write um
you know just text here it will appear
as your window title but anything that
is after the double hash here that just
contributes to the identifier like the
id of the window which is important for
like input events and various other
things like docking but
it
will not appear there like as the text
for the window like this like a title
but um we're not going to see the title
bar because we're going to make this
without decoration anyway so i don't
think it's it matters terribly if it
says toolbar here or if it's after the
hash because we won't see the title
anyway but whatever
um so
we're going to set open to null pointer
this just basically means that there's
no close button because we don't want to
be able to close the toolbar in fact
since it is going to have no decoration
which is the next thing that we're
adding window flags um no decoration
since it is going to have no decoration
then
again we're not going to have a close
button
um
i'm going window flags we've got two
more no scroll bar and then also no
scroll with mouse we don't want to be
able to scroll this stuff in case it
gets too small we might want to set a
minimum size later but that's basically
our imgui window that's our toolbar and
that's what's going to hold that button
right and then we'll dock it up you'll
see in a minute it's much easier when
it's actually visualizable so um
the
kind of main point of here is to have an
image button
which is going to be our texture which
we haven't loaded yet um and then if
that's clicked we want to basically do
on scene play but that depends on the
current state because this button is
going to change into a stop button later
so if the scene
um if m scene state which we haven't
made yet is scene state play right or
rather well it doesn't really matter
what order we do this in let's just do
edit if it's edit then we do on scene
play otherwise if it's uh play we're
going to do on scene stop right because
it's going to be a stop button now
there are other scene states so hazel
has
two others hazel also so there's edit
play there's also pause and then there's
simulate so simulate will run your
physics simulations without actually
starting the game so that's useful if
you're like editing and stuff because
you can still use the editor camera to
fly around and it's nice to have that
unreal engine has a very similar thing
so
um that's uh that's what those are so
that's why i'm kind of writing this not
like a else because what else could it
be because there are potentially other
things um so let's make an enum class
called scene state and this will
basically be edit and then play right
um i'll explicitly kind of label these
just in case we serialize them or do
other things to them
and then let's say c and state m
scene state and then we'll set that to
scene state
edit to begin with okay so on scene play
on scene stop let's make those functions
so
on
scene play on scene stop so
these are actually quite simple
because all we have to do really for
these is set
um scene state to play and then set
scene state to stop
right um i mean in the future we will
probably want to do other stuff to it
i'm just wondering where to put this
uh
maybe let's do it like before on update
that's a layer thing though
i like to keep the layer things
organized maybe we'll do it
i guess we will do it here
put that back
on scene play on scene stop um that's
kind of pretty much like the only things
i think we want to actually do for now
so stop edits is what i meant okay so
this is pretty good let's try and load
those images now so
when we do on attach you can see we load
some kind of texture here we're
basically going to duplicate this stuff
make this um i'll call it icon play and
icon stop
um and then this is just gonna be like
what resources
see if i can remember this at the time i
had resources icons and then like
play icon
maybe
is that is that where we're at
button
whatever
um okay so icon play icon stop um
[Music]
let's do like editor resources ref
texture 2d
icon play icon stop
i guess we can uh kind of pair them like
this because they're
they're relevant to each other scene
states kind of an important thing i
think i might want to put it up here
um okay so play and stop and then again
with the actual icon that we put into
the image button that's going to depend
on
um what state we're in right so icon
equals uh what we'll do is basically
check to see if it's edit
um if it's edit but then we'll make it
play otherwise we'll make it stop so
pretty simple for now um might need to
do some other things in the future
um
but i guess for simulate as well i guess
you could press the simulated button
again to disable simulation i don't know
anyway um so what we'll do is uh icon
get renderer id which will give us a
opengl
id i am texture id
cast heading to enter that
okay now this this next kind of portion
so by the way if we just launch this now
um
[Music]
i don't know how to get this working
okay we need we need to specify a size
so let's make the size um what was the
size here uh well
okay we'll make it in a minute i just
want to show you guys what this looks
like
so
at the moment we have a pretty bare
bones icon simulator so to speak because
what we can now do is click on it to
change the icon pretty cool stuff
um
so if we take this uh
now unfortunately i can't doesn't seem
like i can
dock this anywhere which
is slightly weird
because i definitely should be able to
dock it
uh into where i want
that's weird it's definitely like in the
dark space not that again nothing should
matter no decoration or scroll bar
that's weird do we already have a
toolbar no we can't
why
why is that not dockable
that's super weird
let's try and get rid of the flags for
now just to
see if that does anything
that's bizarre
things went differently on the live
stream there we go now it's dockable
like oh because you have to use it you
have to use the title bar to dock it
interesting
but yeah basically i dock it up here
so that that could be i mean we can pro
we can we can programmatically dock it
as well but that's kind of
um it's a bit annoying but anyway you
can see now we have this amazing thing
where i can hit play and pause and it
will change the icon
so now actually this is a bit of a hack
but if we put this back now it will
remain in the same position because the
imgui ini file
uh which is this actually contains this
hash toolbar right so we we actually
have the doc id and everything here so
we've kind of cheated it because you can
see it's there but um i mean we still
have that tab bar thing uh the
decoration just more or less applies to
the window i guess so there you go
that's how you fix that i guess bit odd
um
so now let's let's do a few things to
the styling of this first of all why is
it uh i don't want it to look like a
button i wanted to kind of blend in with
the interface also
um
[Music]
when i resize this i want the button to
resize with it right so i kind of want
the button to uh basically the colors to
be different i wanted to be in the
middle as well i forgot to mention that
and i wanted to resize so how do i set
that up well it's not too difficult
let's go with
probably setting the size dynamically
first so the way we'll do that is we'll
switch to using size a size variable
instead right
and the size is going to depend on the
current window height and then we're
going to subtract 4. don't ask me why
it's 4 it's just four because
because that's like a nice amount of
padding i guess it just visually looks
nice and you can see now i can resize
this and it will resize with me now
don't worry too much about it kind of
looking like it's touching this it's
because the padding hasn't been done yet
but we kind of noticed another problem
here and it's that this is clearly using
nearest filtering or point filtering
right it's snapping to the nearest kind
of pixel color value it's not leaning
it's not linearly kind of bilinear you
or i should say using bilinear filtering
to actually smooth this out and make it
nice
and all of if you actually look at all
of our textures they look like that and
i discovered that during the stream as
well
why that was the case but it looks like
for all of our textures we set the
minifiguration filters to linear but the
magnification filter to nearest i don't
know where this code came from or why
that's the case but we should definitely
use linear filtering by default the only
reason why you would want nearest
filtering is probably for like things
like pixel art or if you're making
minecraft um for uh well no there's a
lot of rendering techniques behind the
scenes where you might not want to
you know linearly filter your data but
for like actual textures in most games
linear filtering is definitely what you
want repeat you know being on by default
is fine as well that's probably what you
would expect but linear um we definitely
don't want uh nearest filtering by
default very weird to have it for
well no i guess it doesn't matter but
the magnification is the main thing so
if we go back to this now
then um
that kind of problem should be fixed and
you should see a very blurry play button
because again it's tiny it's 32 by 32
but now you can see it's actually
filtering which makes everything else
kind of look a lot nicer when you look
at it if it's like slightly bigger
okay so that's important uh but
otherwise let's continue on with uh
let's maybe change the actual center
position now so to do that we can just
do
i am gooey
same line by the way guys let me know
what you think about like how we're
spending this episode so to speak
because uh i would be totally okay with
skipping some of this ui stuff and maybe
merging it in or copying and pasting it
in um but if you are interested in like
i'm going how to achieve things and i'm
gooey and you you like this commentary
then i i'm happy to do it as well
but um yeah
um
so get window content region max
dot x times point five i'll write this
out first then i'll talk about it
okay so same line first of all means
that the next thing should be on the
same line now there is nothing before
this so really what we're doing is using
same line as a way to actually set an
offset right um again i i i don't
know i'm pretty sure peter initially
wrote this code in
in in real hazel
um because you can also do setka as a
position x i think that will do the the
same thing kind of
same line will will kind of move the
cursor back if it's already dropped it
down because you have another button um
so i guess this makes sense because if
we have multiple buttons then we
probably want to be using same line a
few times for this it doesn't matter for
the first button doesn't matter too much
i guess you can just use that cursor
position x um we might check that in a
minute because i'm curious but uh get
window content region maxx dot sorry max
dot x that is how much space we have
available so in our entire panel our
window is currently
that big that's how i'm going window
called toolbar right so this is asking
it what is the uh how much space do i
have for content right so mine is
padding and stuff what is this size
right and then um obviously once we get
that it basically is the width but it
includes things like padding um and then
we halve it right we multiply by 0.5 so
that gets us into this point over here
which should be the middle the middle of
the window
after that we take how big the button is
going to be right which is that big
remember and that's both the the x and
the y the width and the height of the
button
and we have that and we subtract it so
what that does is takes the button
halves it
and then offsets it by that much to here
so now the cursor for imgui meaning
where the next element will go is here
and obviously if we take this and we
draw the button then guess what we get
we get a button that's centered now for
anyone who has ever centered something
in their lives you understand this but i
thought i would explain it anyway for
people who might be like magic numbers
so um yeah it's very simple you can draw
it on whiteboard and it will make sense
to literally everyone it's probably one
of the first kind of
um
like
layout i get i guess equations that you
probably ever learn
okay so
i guess we should check that out and i
might do my set cursor situation
um my set cursor x situation okay so
there you go so you can see that now it
looks like it's centered again we have
some issues with like the y and the y
location but
we'll check that out in a minute set
cursor position x just want to see if
this does exactly the same thing because
i expect it will
but we will probably still stick to same
line um
same line does more stuff though you
could argue this is better for
performance
um
yeah okay we'll keep it as this but for
other things we might want to do set um
uh
same line not set same line just same
line okay so we have the cursor position
next that's looking good um
now what we want to do
is
uh
yeah basically talk about the padding so
for this window i have a few kind of uh
like variations that i want to make to
the default i'm going style so i can do
that by just pushing style variables and
also pushing
colors as well in a minute so the first
one is window padding so i don't want
any padding in my window
style of
window padding
so
oh sorry i do want some i don't want any
horizontal but i do want two pixels of
vertical padding this is just going to
make it a little like so the button
isn't touching the the bottom like that
then we also have uh item inner spacing
um this is i think the spacing like
extra spacing that's between items or
something we're just basically clearing
that we don't want any of that we want
items to be a little bit closer together
we're also going to get rid of that kind
of outline that they have like the
buttons kind of look like they're
glowing a bit even though they should be
transparent we'll get rid of that as
well
and that's actually the next thing we're
doing so style color
i'm going to style
color uh maybe it's not style what is it
just push
now just push style color
it's just i'm going
color
um
so button so the button color what we're
going to actually do is set this to be a
vec4000 so what this is going to do is
most importantly change that
to zero so that's just going to make it
transparent in the areas that are
transparent that's important
sorry button there's also a button
hovered
and button active
so active when it's clicked hovered is
when your mouse is over it
so same kind of situation but
this this should really be like probably
not hard-coded um because at the moment
i've set them to like these values but
yeah like
i think you might want to well i think
you might want to actually set them to
something else
like for example this i think the reason
i set it to that is because if we look
at the imgui layer
um then we have our own style don't we
yeah so you can see the button hovered
is actually that and then this is that
so i think what we'll do is we'll
actually here's what we'll do we'll be a
bit a bit better about this
um
than i wrote in the live stream
uh see this is what i mean like
improving on stuff is is good as well so
basically this is fine the only thing we
want to change is the alpha value right
so
we're going to get um
basically uh we're going to make an
imvec vect4
um
well no we don't have to do that let's
just do
so colors
and then what was this button hovered
right
uh x
this is a bit annoying though because
it's so big
um
[Music]
i might do that
to in an attempt to shorten this
xyz but then the w we set to that
um and then there's uh also button
active
make this const
um
and then this is button active and then
that
we're gonna basically do the same thing
it's just gonna be button active instead
so the point again of these is to just
lower the opacity to point five that's
what we're doing we're just modifying
that part now finally at the end of all
of this we want to pop everything so if
we do i am gui uh pop so push pushes it
onto the stack pop pops it so pop style
var um and then we can actually put an
account so we have two style vars and
three colors right so um push style
color sorry pop style color three one
two three colors two vars okay looks
good let's preview that and that should
hopefully give us a much nicer looking
button
okay so you can see that um i'm not sure
but was it supposed to kind of show up
like that
i don't really remember what it looked
like
but
i guess that's all right the point is
you can see we can just we until we
hover i guess that's fine until we hover
we just yeah we're kind of um
we see we see through it into the
background and it looks like it's the
same color color as the background so
that's that's the effect of putting a
zero kind of opacity over here well a
zero value for the alpha channel um okay
so that looks like pretty much
everything that we could want um i think
there's one one last final thing and
that is with this image button there's
actually a parameter called frame
padding and we want to set that to zero
because it's not currently zero so to do
that we need to get through these two uv
parameters so we'll say um i am vector
zero zero i'm vector one one
and then finally zero so we've changed
the frame padding from a default value
of negative one to being zero instead so
let's take a look at that
okay and you can see now it actually
looks like it's properly centered right
so that was important so congratulations
if you've made it this far
maybe i'll start chaptering these videos
so you can skip certain certain sections
that you may not be interested in i
don't know guys correct me if i'm wrong
but i feel like no one was interested in
any in anything they'll just like give
me the code you know i'll just copy and
paste this beautiful style you've made
but that no a lot goes into iron gooey
stuff um so yeah believe me i know
okay so now let's actually make the
button do something so how do we
demonstrate doing something at the
moment we don't really have a simulation
like a physics simulation to do well
there's actually like already something
that we were using the run time so to
speak for and that is if we load
something like the ping cube scene we
have a camera in the scene right and
when we hit play i want to be able to
look at the scene from the point of view
of the camera now that's very easy to do
because all we realistically need to do
is just run a different function than we
are at the moment we're running on
update editor which again takes in an
editor camera and draws sprites from the
point of view of the camera i want to
instead do the function above which is
on update runtime which again finds a
camera in the scene and then uses that
so to do that
by the way the whole layout of this i
was discussing this during the live
stream the whole layout of this is a bit
weird like we need to probably create
something called a scene renderer so
that we can actually render scenes um
through there instead of from the editor
layer and then binding some frame
buffers that the editor layer owns it's
a bit weird usually you'd have like the
way that the proper hazel works is it
has a
um it has a scene renderer right you can
create as many of them as you want uh
for different viewports and stuff you
give it a scene as like the context and
its result is i'll give you a texture
i'll give you a texture with
the scene right right like based on
whatever settings whatever like modes
you enable so you might not want post
processing you might not want bloom you
might not want um i don't know certain
other things it will give you based on
your parameters a texture and then you
can take that texture um and actually
you can tell the scene renderer render
directly to the swap chain if it's
something that is running in the runtime
like without the editor standalone like
a game or
if you don't do that then it will
instead give you a texture which you can
ask it for later and that texture is
what you can pass into imgui so we'll
talk a little bit more about that design
and how to integrate it here because
that's important um that's probably
something i should put into the renderer
thing i'm not logged in for some reason
here but um that's something that we'll
definitely put into renderer and we'll
talk about like making a proper scene
renderer but for the time being what we
need to do is um
this section here but there's also some
other stuff that we don't want so for
example edit a camera update camera
controller i don't even know what we're
using camera controller for because i'm
pretty sure editor camera does all of
this stuff right so and this is like
camera control is an orthographic camera
control like what are we actually doing
here this was i think for the game kind
of thing right when we had an orthograph
when we had like a top-down game or
something i don't know it's weird but
the point being that what we'll do is
over here when it's time to update the
scene because this actually does since
it does rendering um on update editor
right we'll call end scene which
actually we'll call flush which will uh
do draw indexed which will actually you
know do an opengl draw call uh that's
contextual that's that needs this frame
buffer bound and it needs to be cleared
first right so we can't do it up here we
have to do it here so because of that if
we just do switch on the uh current
scene state right then if it's edit
i'll actually open up some curly
brackets here because
we might have a considerable amount of
code here that i want to have a proper
scope
and then i'll
i'll indent that in because i prefer
that um we're going to do on update
editor right inside here
um otherwise we'll do on update run time
and that doesn't need an end camera now
this stuff
also will happen here right so again i
don't think we need this but we'll we'll
worry about removing it some other time
that i believe
is actually surprisingly all we maybe
need now this isn't like a proper run
time i mean we would want to every time
we hit play like in real hazel we copied
the scene into a new scene that is our
actively running scene that way
obviously when we hit stop we have a
scene to restore um actually it's
actually still retained in memory so we
don't even have to worry about loading
it but when you hit play it makes a copy
of the scene that you can play around
with that way you can obviously simulate
the physics move stuff around and you
can reset to that editor scene version
um so let's uh see see if this works so
if i hit play awesome look at that so
when i hit play i can have this editor
camera wherever i hit play it moves me
back to wherever that runtime kind of
well well not the runtime camera but
wherever the camera entity with the
component is at
um and then when i hit stop obviously
i'm returned back to here so that's
pretty cool um i can take the camera and
move it
let's just move it really like far away
um and i hit play and you can see now
it's way further now this gizmo still
appears here
we should probably fix that but um
that's basically that's gonna be it if
someone wants to fix the gizmo submit a
pull request we should probably have
like a maintenance episode where i fixed
all these little things um because
otherwise like these videos are gonna be
very long but yeah so there we go we now
have a way to play our scenes let's take
out take a look at this scene beautiful
and this 3d example there we go so these
these are in three space ones further
away than the other even though they're
the same size so
there you go that is basically the
runtime working so what will happen is
once we do in fact have box 2d
um
that play will actually
start simulating the physics as well
which is pretty cool and then when we
have c sharp scripting which is after
after that that will also run the you
know oncreate functions for all the
entities and then the on update
functions every frame so uh this is kind
of important and obviously as you can
see it's the basis for a lot but anyway
i hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please don't forget to hit the
like button don't forget the source code
is on the
content browser branch a little bit
weird should probably merge that back in
i don't think we're quite done with the
content browser i think that if we try
and drag like a texture into the
viewport instead of a scene it will
crash um there's a few things to fix
there but uh we might do like a bit of a
stability pass at some point i might
even do that during the week or maybe
i'm not sure we'll see because i do want
to get like one major episode of actual
work done every single week don't forget
to follow twitch.tv slash the channel to
know when i'm next live um there's a
schedule there as well with all of the
work that's going to happen for the next
episode patreon.com best way to help
support this series as well as get
access to hazel and um
other than that i hope you guys enjoyed
this new kind of chapter that we've
begun with hazel 2d i'll see you next
week goodbye
[Music]
you